it's cleared by Matthews who gives it up
for Hachi Mora who he loves the
mid-range market against Nick steps
through 415 fountain being we're telling
him and of course that's grown watch
this move right here watch the shot fake
little step through but you know again I
don't want to be compared Robinson the
good eye Hachi Murrah gets it into 14
feet and connects pretty good good shot
fake by the way I think they ought to
move the NBA line back to 25 feet it's a
23 nine right now why do you think that
would be better
he's gonna make pretty good money with
that first NBA contract but he's gonna
wait make way more money and all those
endorsements back home in Japan where
although baseball is a national sport
the bat we talked about how good he is
in the mid-range and how he reminds me a
little bit of Kawhi Leonard on to the
Green Bay in Luxemburg next thing you
know he's in the NBA Finals and it goes
back to what I said run your own race
look at this now what he adds that watch
out now watch this now he shoots a flat
ball okay but maybe an NBA athlete right
now but we're trying to show his wares
do you think with another I want a block
by Hachi Marat is right now if you think
about it is teams the future is now
right for the Lakers the Clippers the
Nets then the future is the future for
teams like Memphis and Washington
Atlanta good a little pick-and-roll
action right here by copain and you know
listen this is summer league this is
like double a dislike the double-a
baseball all-star game okay my cousins
Fran Fraschilla with you her the Thomas
& Mack Center Atlanta up by two and
Hachi Morra evens the school George
wanted out he wanted to go to the Lakers
with with Kawhi Leonard
and they Sam Presti happy trader what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
leads to report make sure you subscribe
for some more video content